here we go warning the following content
might upset you may contain traces of
irony skepticism and dark humors a
random set of amazing genes that was
vagina look at me look at me look at me
look at my face
zoom in on that bad boy right there that
is the picture of beauty look at the
shapely nose the luscious brows I am one
handsome baby also I'm a big baby and I
was a big baby at 10 pounds in 3 ounces
I was a whopping baby uh I want
subtitles on ok interesting translations
on I don't know what translations mean
translations on I guess Dada or mama I
gotta call my mom I'll just go with what
I did
oh by the way welcome to imagine life
times I haven't said that yet it's a
game where you imagine your lifetime now
let me call my mom so I had a question
I'm playing a game and it's asking me
what my first words were did I say mama
or Dada da first when I was a baby
yeah okay so I said mama clearly okay
domi I remember we have a picture yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay all right so I said mom really I'll
so I crushed my own brother s which
makes perfect sense okay click the lock
to continue okay locked in baby you knew
it I knew it too I'm listening where we
send you out into the world you're going
to have to make some important decisions
Wow my favorite childhood toy
hi sorry
one more one more quick question did I
have a favorite childhood toy this this
game I'm playing is just asking me about
my childhood I mean we were so poor we
didn't have toys right so my favorite
toy was sitting in the middle of a room
staring and smiling this is true okay
thank you
all right parents stared smile sure
whatever man
well I don't know what this is I'm gonna
go with this mr. cool all right mr. claw
[Laughter]
SARS call my real mom of which you are
not choices you're about to make will
affect your
characters traits strengths and
weaknesses in life
aha no okay I got it what is this what
is this
we got paint we got reading and building
okay
just last thing less thing I'm sorry I'm
sorry are you okay
so it's it's got one more thing about me
and kindergarten okay do you remember
what my favorite activity in
kindergarten was in kindergarten oh no
when when I was actually in school yeah
yeah yeah what did I do study okay like
a smart kid very quiet
was I sitting and staring and smiling in
kindergarten I was perfectly annalen I
sound like a supervillain I sound like a
manipulator and boy with the big big
brain I got it thanks okay cool all
right cool thank you thank you okay so
apparently I would spend my days in
kindergarten judging people and studying
whoa what the hell what was that let's
go with reading because of no idea okay
I'm gonna go with reading because sure
yeah right away once you're done with
these you'll be ready to face whatever
is out there for sure oh my god choose
some friends well I mean I think it was
true
when I was in school I didn't really
have friends it was like one friend and
then the teacher I think this is the
teacher but I added like one friend his
name was I think it was Daniel maybe you
look like a Daniel in the driver's seat
I like that you're you riding shotgun I
like that I'm good with this I think
this I didn't have many friends growing
up there we go mm-hmm
choose my playground adventures oh my
god I was all am i picking here we're
sitting alone hiding from effort but I
remember we had this really disgusting
sandbox that all the Wildcats would you
know [ __ ] in and I was playing it by
myself until I finally learned that it's
kind of disgusting there no seesaws no
bikes no hide-and-seek's just me sitting
alone at a sandbox and that's it thanks
I would hope so
Wow look like a pimple I don't even know
what that looks like but I'm pretty sure
a taint of imple all right am I supposed
to pop this okay I had a lot of acne
growing up I did oh I don't want any
part of this I don't want anything to do
with it oh my god here we go
[Music]
looks like so much grown up yeah I
didn't do none of these oh wait no I did
track and field is out this is this is
my life to the most accurate so in high
school I did do track and field so I
think that this is a track and field I
did do that I'm trying to be the most
accurate to my life because my life is
amazing so I just want to recreate the
elements for that choose my crush
[ __ ] yeah what in the back just yeah you
look generally like my high school
girlfriend I think is that are we still
in high school I guess that's the last
time I had a crush on someone I'm
guessing you Olivia so swing miss mrs.
Robinson art Quinn Rick Vivien sleek Tex
thank you she's an after-school activity
nothing gaming after school I did not
have a smartphone if we're still in high
school I did not have a smartphone
I just didn't it's not a thing not when
I was growing up but I did have some
sweet gaming adventures oh god damn
mouth mom my first part-time job
probably the closest would be retail
cashier I worked at Kroger I was not a
cashier but I wasn't in the food
department either so that's probably
closest thanks you didn't really have a
choice oh my god oh my god okay where's
it biomedical engineering okay can I
only check one
I can check what is your heart telling
you wait what
Oh weird well this is pretty indicative
of what I did
oh I can't go back all right whatever
that's pretty good enough I did bounce
back and forth between the two what I
did was more engineering than biology
but I was trying to go to med school at
first and so that's what I did right
right thanks thank you I saw that is
pretty accurate I I went back and forth
yeah this is me being for my extra life
because I didn't actually graduate Wow
I get to choose my path travel path
career path recommended partner path
housing path not recommended family path
blocked requires partner marriage path
blocked retirement path blocked man I
was a late bloomer in the partner aspect
of things so that was not it and I was
definitely not about that career life
this is important
choose your search method Oh Internet
baby Internet baby all the way internet
faith B what the hell is this this is
not this is not my career what is this
where's let's play where is that okay I
was kind of going into the medical field
I was biomedical engineering so I was
working it I was working it Oh No maybe
it's a tough call mom don't you back off
[ __ ] I guess I'll go research scientist
sure why not
where's less player where can I make a
hard shift oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh that's not bad oh my god actually
wait no that's real bad Oh four days a
week okay
loads of benefits okay survived my first
day of work the boss you must be our
latest recruit
[Music]
uh-huh uh-huh let's get me started
Felicia okay friendly colleague hi there
welcome aboard the team I want to show
you around a bit just get everything in
the green I'm Way ahead of you I'm Way
ahead of you I'm green baby give me that
green mm Oh God
let's do the nine nine eight seven six
five four three two one
oh boy not bad okay cool
oh man did you see nine I don't know did
you see a nine oh god okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay oh my god stop stop
stop stop stop stop oh my god oh my god
okay hey whatever whoo difficult boss
paychecks are a bit delayed well that
seems highly illegal just wait a little
longer
well that seems odd I will pay you soon
enough seems highly suspect oh here it
is
wait I didn't okay yay money I think
great it's good your first paycheck I've
done it travel path blocked requires
freedom oh no you I can't I have no
freedom I don't have freedom all right
fine time to lock myself down even
harder that's where we go into the
partner bath baby let's do this let's
find a partner
your love life coming god-awful give me
those ladies click right to approve Wow
Fiona Diana
kaboom silly there she is boom
hi big home Bethany sorry Beth Chelsea
yeah Patricia loved it
Sarah sure Laura maybe not Gina why not
Zoe Sharon lay Nicole what do you mean
don't be too picky Madison Olivia Hilary
Quinn
Tina Cara Rachel
Ariana Jude vaca-oom oh did I do it
choose a partner Wow who is this uma Zoe
Fiona
eenie meenie miney moe catch a tiger by
the toe if he hollers let him go eeny
meeny miny moe moe four so what's up so
what's up so don't tell Amy she's your
type of date in the shop I like going
lightbulb shopping I am not the romantic
type I will say that right now I'm not
the adventurous type and I'm not the
intellectual type where's the date that
I take you to my favorite fast-food
restaurant and then make everything
really awkward and just absolutely
stumble over myself and put my foot in
my mouth
I guess adventurous cuz it's not
Romantica it's not smart let's do it
choose my next move make it official
escape one-time thing well I mean in for
a pet what was her name again
Zoe in for a penny in for a pound
let's make it official this is obviously
clearly true love Oh wonderful so oh you
know I sat in a room smiling to myself
my favorite hobby partner path complete
repeatable I don't
think I want to see housing path sure ah
yes yes yes yes no screw that give me a
nice house with a yard for a dog that's
what I want
cozy cottage y'all good god yes please
dear god I'm tired just thinking about
that Oh horse Chico Chico size of my
television give me the big one
duh I'm a research scientist I could
afford it type of decor ooh I like the
cactus Oh weeping fig now Croton I like
that well what can I say I'm in fact
incredible all right let's start pumping
out baby before marriage
how sacrilegious let's do it how weird
can I make this choose the delivery
method DIY adoption IVF it was an
accident
a big ol oopsy poopsy and then pooped
out a baby no my monetization
no what is death it is inevitable duh
inevitable we all know this do dishonest
baby what is the universe conceivable
[Music]
all right what is your body
oh it's deteriorating every day
nice man this this sperm are getting
real real philosophical what is time
ticking hey this is this Loomis honestok
game oh this is unas honest the game
ain't it oh it's a little pessimistic
but hey you got the heart what is
significant nothing nothing don't want
no dumbass baby yes yes right come on
come on what is confusing this answer
nice nice nice nice nice you get in
there yeah I did it
I've done it I've done it
repeatable oh it's repeatable all right
all right there first comes love and
then comes marriage that's the order
Oh size of ring look baby I'm on a
budget baby babe I'm on a budget look I
put that TV I bought it's real weight
[Music]
right Oh
I can get a discount right there
nailed it well played well played indeed
thank you I know how to do this
not even to [ __ ] nobody please oh my
god nobody it's just the least amount
possible please okay there we go
it's just nobody please nobody show up I
hope that none of those get their color
the napkins oh who cares white so you
can see the food you're wiping size of a
cake all for me baby all for me saved
all that money so I could blast it on a
cake babe I did it divorce path oh not
recommended
Oh No which basment like not recommended
was it like the childhood path
beforehand yeah you know let's assume
let's assume everything works out and we
could just crawl quietly define oh yeah
retirement home how do I take a seat
boink oh god no oh here I go into the
sweet embrace of death oh the darkness
has come to claim me Oh God
oh it's comfortable alright holy
neverending ticking clock god this is
just honest honest the game oh my god
it's the ticking clock until the end of
your meaningless existence which I
disagree with I think the meaning is
what you make of it it may not seem
meaningful the rule there I go and I'm
dead
you it happens yeah yeah yeah guys if
you could start over what would you
change anything
not a goddamn thing no not a single
thing now thank you there's my dog
there's the roses and there is a log
there's a frog in the bog there's my
cache oh what a jug going back in time
now I play games I am a cow dragon field
oh what a deal gonna steal all the
mobiles I don't know oh here I go a
[Music]
Barbara oh my god this board I was
talking random place
at a random time
[Music]
with a random set of genes I love it I
love it I'm all about look at you I'm
all about it okay alright so that was
imagine lifetimes a really interesting
game I like the concept I like what it's
got going on there there's a lot to love
about that and this was just a demo of
what could come out of this game so life
is yours to choose you gotta make your
own choices and sometimes you don't know
where those choices are going to lead
you but always remember even though the
time is always running out for all of us
we decide our destinies
we choose what we do with the time we
have left so thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you to my mom for
giving me insight about my childhood
apparently I sat alone in a room staring
and smiling at everyone around me and
judging them for being stupider than I
am which sounds very appropriate for
what I was as a child so I'm just gonna
sit stare and smile at you until the end
of this video and hopefully you will be
smart enough to make the right choices
to like subscribe ring the bell and
watch more of my fun videos linked in
the description or the suggested videos
[Music]